hey what is up guys I'm Kitty HD here
and click video so I'm about to finish
up my junior year of college in a couple
weeks which means two things one I am
about to dive headfirst into finals week
and two when I'm done with finals week
I'm going to have way more time to
actually make videos as you guys know
not having class every day makes for way
more time to work on things I enjoy like
video so basically there's gonna be a
lot of fun stuff coming up breaking out
of the box I guess you could say I've
already teased some of this at really
just one of the videos that I'm talking
about but a lot of fun stuff coming up
but this particular video is very simple
it is a giveaway of the mkbhd Edition
Nexus 5 now you guys have actually seen
this before I showed it in a previous
video it's really a white 32 gigabyte
Nexus 5 with the mkbhd skin from deep
brand pre-installed plus you get some
fancy mkbhd Edition packaging from deep
brand they put this package together so
hey maybe the winner can do an unboxing
video so all you have to do to get
entered to win this phone is to be a
subscriber of the C Tube channel and
leave one comment right below telling me
whatever one comment equals one entry
and you can only enter once so make it a
good comment and the winner will be
chosen randomly and it'll be in one week
so on Sunday May 4th that's when we're
gonna be picking the winner and if that
winner happens to also be a follower of
mkbhd on twitter i'll also throw in a
pair of the blue and brown audio
technica ath and fifty headphones so
it's all more incentive to follow on
twitter we'll be announcing the winner
on twitter so that's a good place to
keep tuned to and i guess that's another
reason you'll have two of my favorite
gadgets on your way to your box if you
happen to win and i'll ship this box
anywhere in the world so you can be in
whatever country it doesn't really
matter as long as you can accept
packages at your address you're eligible
to enter this giveaway so I'll include
the link to subscribe right below the
like button I'll include the link to my
Twitter right below and also I'll throw
down the D brand twitter account link
you might as well follow them they are
the ones that put this package together
they're the ones that made the custom
mkbhd skin and
if you win you're gonna be one of two
people in the world to actually have
this skin on your phone you and I if you
happen to win so we'll have that special
connection so thanks to D brand for
putting this together again I'll have
that shout-out link right below now an
obligatory disclaimer this giveaway will
be ending in the afternoon of Sunday May
4th my time it will not be ending early
I say this because every time there's a
giveaway on YouTube there seems to be a
bunch of people that go around and make
fake accounts that's supposed to look
like me and message of much people
telling them they won and asking them
for information the only way to tell if
the message actually came from me
there's a probably a bunch of
impersonator marques Brownlee accounts
on YouTube but there's only one with the
verified checkmark next to it so if you
want to make sure you're actually
getting a message for me on YouTube it
will be the one with a checkmark next to
it so if you're looking out for that
message on Sunday May 4th that's how you
know it came from me and of course on
Twitter you'll be able to see more
details about the giveaway if anything
ever changes about it which is unlikely
Twitter will be the place to stay tuned
for that
so there you go guys that's basically it
for this quick simple giveaway video
hopefully you'll get entered and best of
luck if you do and like I said there's a
lot of stuff a lot of fun stuff coming
up even another giveaway I have planned
very shortly down the road so I'll see
you there thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you all the next one peace